no
carol desperately wants to go home i'm
not all grateful i know i just
but you don't know beauty you know she
suffers from chronic lung disease
and caught covered
she's been well enough to go home since
the 7th of january but she can't because
the hospital can't find care for her in
the community
really upset i am
what would make you feel safer and
better what make you happier to go home
number one
and number two to know i've got care
and sooner they're better together
carol is one of
128 patients in dudley's russell's hall
hospital who shouldn't be here carol's
story is typical of what is happening in
the nhs right now and it's one of the
health services biggest challenges
in this hospital alone they could fill
five wards with a number of patients who
are medically fit to be discharged but
can't be because there isn't any
provision in the community for them
it's a huge problem
last week there were almost 12
400 beds in england taken up by patients
who no longer needed to be there in a
care home if you've got two members of
staff that are positive for covered or
two patients then that care home is
closed for 14 days and you can't then
discharge patients back into it so again
those patients then remain in hospital
until they can go back to that
particular care home so that is causing
us some problems we're not blaming
anybody we're working together we have
to make sure that we can discharge
patients safely and that's really
important
the staffing crisis that's stopping
patients from being discharged is
affecting every part of the nhs
here in dudley there's been a five-fold
increase in covid related staff absences
since the end of november our situation
is better this week than last week
however we are preparing for the
aftermath of the christmas festivities
we are expecting in the next week or so
that you may see an increase in stuff
absences we've seen the community
prevalence increasing day by day as
staff absences rose so too did the
number of covered patients
there are 80 being cared for by the
trust right now
and half
like richard
are unvaccinated i was never expecting
this life
you know you've been being fit and
healthy and then all of a sudden i'm
sort of gasping for air you know just
never in a million years
somewhere has been found for carol
it won't be long before her bed is
filled again
the pressure
is relentless ashish joshi sky news
at the russell's hall hospital in dudley